recently rainbow six siege pro league
player louise
admitted to using a new undetectable
cheat in a ranked match
his account was banned and he was
indefinitely suspended from his
org on top of that the coach for that
same org
was accused of grooming and gaslighting
an underage girl
these two controversies highlight a
complicated story that started nearly a
year ago
one that's captivated the siege world
[Music]
hello people watching this video like
the video
subscribe to the channel and hit that
notification bell so you never miss a
siege story ever again
and if there's a story that you want to
see us cover on don't at me
send a tip to tips at thescore.com okay
first let me explain this cheating
situation
back on april 21st clips of pro league
player louise
allegedly cheating in a ranked match
started making the rounds on twitter
he's supposed to try it out for himself
you're watching what
yo yo yo
in all three clips you can hear the
enemy comms in complete disbelief over
louise allegedly cheating
on twitter the response was similar
people clearly thought this guy was
cheating
not long after that luis said that no he
wasn't cheating and that he just got
lucky
then shortly after that according to him
his account was manually banned by
someone at ubisoft
or face it and face it if you didn't
know helps ubisoft run
siege pro league what's important to
note here is that the ban is apparently
unrelated to battle eye which is
ubisoft's automatic anti-cheat detection
system
from there luis posted a now deleted
twitlonger admitting that yes he did
cheat in one ranked game
on one map on one round he even gives
the specifics to how he did it and we'll
get to that in just a second
quote this was a big mistake and i
[ __ ] up when the clips started getting
a lot of attention i got scared and lied
saying that it was luck which in
hindsight was also a mistake
for those that don't know what the
wireframe is it is an exploit graphic
bug in-game that can be toggled on
through intel monitor graphics
here's what it looks like this has been
a big mistake and will never happen
again
end quote now i interviewed louise and
the first thing i asked him to do was
expand on why he cheated
here's an absurdly talented kid playing
for a team
that qualified for the biggest
tournament of the year
why throw it all away it was just a dumb
mistake
i i was just curious i guess i used it
for the first round and then i turned it
off i was like this is just so dumb i'm
not i'm
and i deleted it like round two i was
like this is it like this was such a
guy i shouldn't have done that this is
so dumb
and like the only thing that could
happen happened
so yeah again according to him he used
the cheat for one round on one map
realized what he was doing was
incredibly stupid and then allegedly
turned it off
now towards the end of his twitlonger
louise talks about this wireframe
exploit that you can toggle on and off
and apparently it's related to intel's
graphics performance
analyzer more specifically the exploit
could be found within a
free intel nvidia program that was easy
to download
and essentially it turned off walls
here's a clip of someone named nuke
explaining and calling out the exploit
on twitter
hey yo i'm about to show you how to do
the wireframe [ __ ] so it can get passed
so listen bro
you open google you either just type
intel gpa
download then it's gonna do like this
[ __ ]
gives you uh windows download how do we
have it so it doesn't matter
what the [ __ ] all right now you go there
graphics monitor so it's going to
download
just do a open as admin all right now
you're in that [ __ ] so you just go
there you put everything here on
and then you go in uh there shortcuts
and then show our frame you just bind
the key you want
now you just do that [ __ ] and then you
open the game and then you press
whatever key you set it up to
then you can have free wallets so yeah
i'm a possession on twitter
please ubisoft just this is this is
crazy a siege community developer
replied that that exploit was patched
nuke said no it wasn't and provided
another clip at this point in time it's
unclear if this exploit has been fully
patched and this isn't like one of those
cheating subscriptions that you pay for
that we've covered on this show in the
past
no this is free software that you can
easily just
download now when i asked louise to help
me understand
why at first he denied cheating then
admitted to it in a twit longer but then
deleted that twit longer
he said that he panicked and essentially
didn't want those clips to go viral
yeah yes i was scared because i like the
only thing that could happen happened
and uh i knew i made a mistake i was
like i [ __ ] up so bad
now after louise admitted to cheating
parabellum esports the org that he was
signed to
released this statement quote we are
aware of the current situation in
regards to louise pb
parabellum does not condone cheating by
any of our players
louise has been suspended indefinitely
without pay from parabellum rainbow six
louise was not one of the members
joining our roster for the sixth
invitational
that roster will be revealed in the
coming days we have requested
information on next steps from ubisoft
in regards to the remainder of the nacl
season we will update as information is
given to us
end quote now parabellum says that
they've reached out to ubisoft for
further instruction
but so far ubisoft has not publicly said
anything about the incident
i also reached out to parabellum for
comment here's what they had to say what
i can say right now
is that um we are uh communicating with
ubisoft and faceit
um as uh they are currently uh
investigating the whole situation still
um so we uh we we did wait to
to suspend him until uh until the band
uh
was uh was official um and then we we
suspended him indefinitely
um and we are currently uh like i said
in contact with ubisoft and are
currently waiting
um some for some more information in
regards to the next steps
with louise and what's going to happen
with him so that was the recent cheating
news but
let's back up and talk about how we got
here because frankly
the lead-up to this incident is pretty
severe this complicated story begins in
2020 with the now defunct canadian
division of ubisoft's new
rainbow six siege pro league which
debuted in may
of that year in theory the new lan
league was supposed to be based in las
vegas
and all of the teams participating were
supposed to live there but then the
pandemic happened which caused a lot of
orgs to back
out of this new league dropping entire
rosters with little notice
this pissed a lot of people off and
caused a lot of controversy early on
we covered this story extensively at the
time
after pro league season 11 ended in may
ubisoft
ended their contract with esl and over
the next
year ubisoft debuted a new version of
pro league that we're currently in
right now anyway a relatively unknown
org named alteora
completely destroyed the limited
competition in the canadian league
and won the entire thing then in
december altiora beat a bunch of tier 1
orgs like disrupt gaming and supersonics
to qualify for the 6th invitational the
esports most prestigious tournament and
for a small canadian
squad to qualify for siege's biggest
tournament
was a giant deal at the time i mean just
look at how hyped these guys are
working in tandem with one another
they've managed to take control of cafe
and rudy will go in one direction with
their spirits up and he'll pick up his
third kill
sonar gets it and the kings of canada
will compete at the six invitational
punching their ticket and defeating the
east coast by a score
of three to two but then a month later
in january 2021 ubisoft shuttered the
canadian division
citing covet as a primary reason and
merged it all
into one giant north american division
altiora's entire roster was dropped with
basically no warning
and the guys that had just qualified for
s i
were now without a team for a while it
looked like altiora was going to find a
replacement us-based
roster but then in february ubisoft
announced that the org was leaving siege
esports entirely
again citing covid as a primary reason
a month after that in march parabellum
esports picked up
altor's original roster but replaced
euphoria in sonar with
luis the player who cheated earlier and
kool-aid
the sentiment at the time was okay cool
this
slightly different looking but still
insanely talented roster
still has a chance to compete at the six
invitational luis specifically had a lot
of heat behind him and by all accounts
was considered a rising talent with a
bright future ahead of him but
shortly after he joined parabellum
esports in march
everything started to fall apart for
everyone
on april 13th parabellum released a
statement announcing that the org had
opened an investigation into
its coach awkward one hp quote we have
opened an investigation regarding our
rainbow six coach
awkward one hp as of april 13th 2021
we are suspending awkward without pay
from the parabellum esports men
and women's roster while we complete
this investigation
there will be no contact between any
members of the organization
except for executives at this time
awkward will not be eligible to work
with the team
during the remainder of the nacl or
travel with the team for the upcoming 6
invitation we at parabellum esports
condemn
any actions that may threaten the safety
or damage
any of our members our community or our
brand
we thank everyone for their patience and
support while we investigate
end quote shortly after parabellum's
first statement awkward released a
twitlonger announcing his retirement
from siege esports
quote all good things must come to an
end i've been in the esports scene for
siege through the past five years
from console all the way to pc and have
worked with so many different people and
teams
and have enjoyed a large portion of it
with me now graduating college and
needing to refocus onto my
apprenticeship for the next five years
retirement was to be expected i'd like
to thank everyone that helped me get to
where i am today
and i'll see you all around end quote at
this point the r6 scene had
little context as to what the hell
happened with awkward
and shortly after he released his
retirement twit longer
parabellum released another statement
quote with the recent news of our coach
awkward retiring from esports we would
like to give an update on the situation
we were approached by several members of
the rainbow six siege esports community
with serious allegations towards awkward
our team
immediately opened an investigation this
investigation will be ongoing regardless
of the decision he has made to retire
the next day on april 14th a woman named
alessa
posted a twitlonger titled the truth
behind me
in awkward in it she states that she was
16 when her and awkward began talking
she accuses him of lying about his age
trying to solicit nude photos from her
and generally sending sexually explicit
messages
when she says she was just looking for a
platonic friendship
quote as he made these comments i never
really engaged or flirted back
as i thought it was inappropriate but i
did not want to say anything about it
because i did not want to believe that
he had ill intent
i just wanted a friendship with him and
i figured that he eventually would get
my hints
that i was not interested like that end
quote from there
she says that friends got involved and
started asking awkward about the nature
of their relationship
alyssa says that it was at this point
that awkward started getting defensive
and started quote bashing alessa to
anyone who would listen
alyssa says that she confronted him
about this and that according to her
awkward acted like he didn't care and
the two began
arguing about what he allegedly has said
about her it was at this point that
alyssa says she talked to a friend about
what to do next
quote i told our friend about how matt
had been making inappropriate comments
to me for weeks before that
and they recommended that i go to
parabellum to report him
they got me in contact with parabellum
staff members and i explained the entire
situation
this led to an investigation and awkward
then retiring end quote
here's one of the final paragraphs of
her twitlonger quote
i feel disgusted with him i dealt with
his inappropriate comments and
gaslighting for weeks
i know that i should have said something
to end it earlier and i failed to do so
the situation definitely could have
ended up way worse than what it did
but it still does not make this
situation okay
i did not ask for this to happen to me
he should not have been inappropriately
speaking to a minor
a minor cannot lead an adult on his
comments were inappropriate and he needs
to take responsibility
end quote this brings us all the way
back around to louise's cheating
incident which was made public
a week after the situation with awkward
went down it was a pretty tough month
for para bellum
think about it you jump into siege
esports and pick up a supremely talented
roster
one that's already qualified for the
biggest tournament of the year
you imagine they'd be [ __ ] ecstatic
fast forward a month
and yes the roster is still qualified
for the sixth invitational
but now they're missing their coach who
is accused of grooming a minor
and one of their best players who
admitted to cheating as for louise i'm
of two minds
on the one hand i get it he cheated he
knew what he was doing and there's no
getting around that
so should he face some sort of
punishment but if it was for one round
on one map and then he turned it off
because he knew what he was doing with
stupid and we can prove that
maybe we can give the guy a break
because of one dumb mistake
for the rest of his competitive days
he'll be known as the supremely talented
player who cheated
and potentially threw away a shot at
lifting that giant [ __ ]
s.i hammer towards the end of the
interview i asked louise what was next
for him
and i gave him a moment to address the
siege scene
here's what he had to say i just want to
like apologize to like everyone involved
with the situation the ubisoft face it
my friends my team it was
it was like the biggest mistake for my
part i don't expect the community to
forgive me
right away but i'm ready to take the
time
needed to make up for it if i get a
second chance
then i will take it
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this
hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite size
videos you won't find anywhere else
hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages